pitching better recently has been
pitching deeper into games and that
fastball about 60 of the time at the top
of the zone he's not afraid he goes out
there he tries to work ahead and then
improved with the off speed his last
timeout and
big pop up near first base ceno
almost standing on top of it
makes the catch one away
i'm ed rosario the dh tonight he is
hitting 355 in the month of
august ground ball nice stop by simmons
and a nice scoop at first by suno
always thought
it has to be tougher doesn't it of the
first baseman over there trying to
scoop out a low throw on the backhand
side simmons tested two batters in a
fine stop to his left a low throw dug
out by miguel good play all around danny
two outs jose ramirez
is now seventh in the american league in
extra base
slaps one the other way that is a fair
ball
and that'll kick off the side while jose
will roll into second base
with a two out double his 24th on the
year and he shot one the opposite way
and the indians have a two out double
leonard second base no score and the
payoff pitch lined into right field near
the line coming in kepler slides and
makes the catch
with some sod coming off the ground and
right the twins defense
on point in the opening inning tonight
and a run-saving play by kepler and
wright
denies cleveland a first inning scoring
chance
morgan is making his 11th start on the
year and five on the road he's made four
starts this will be start number five
looking for his first win coming off a a
tough start for him against oakland you
know he had a string of going at least
five innings he only went four but he
didn't have his command in that ball
game he's gonna need it tonight
and that's perfectly defensed by andreas
jimenez who was in
the optimal position to make that play
one down
swing and a miss the changeup got him
two down strikeout number one for eli
morgan here's jorge polacco switch
hitter batting left-handed here's pitch
number 16 from eli morgan
swing and a miss he finally won the
battle
16 pitches it took to strike out polanco
indians and twins scoreless after one
ref snyder
batting 308 couple of homers 10 rbis
the pitch
and the check swing tamper to the mound
morgan up with it to home for one ramos
throw to first double play
how about that
base is loaded nobody out
morgan strikes out ceno
and ref snyder with a check swing tamper
to the mound and it's a one two three
ending ending double play
top of the order now miles straw popped
up his first time up
swing on banged up the middle behind
second knocked down on the backhand by
polanco picked up by simmons and throws
the ball in the dugout
wow
for a moment you thought maybe a double
play simmons
picked up the backhand at carom he
kicked the bag at second for the out but
then threw the ball into the dugout and
the one two swag and a miss and down he
goes on a fastball up and inside
and that was the pitch if you go back to
wednesday's game against the white sox
that location against andrew vaughn he
could not lay off that pitch and he
struck out three times
polanco into the corner
zimmer cuts it off polanco will be held
to a single nice job by zimmer and his
speed which was so much of an asset for
him in center field
comes in handy in right field too here's
the pitch to you chang who launches one
high and deep to right this one's way
back there and that ball bangs off the
wall on his way to second is chang and
he's in with a sliding double
to open things up in the fifth inning
for the tribe
with a lead off double and he just
missed hitting it out of here the other
way so the leadoff man in scoring
position now for daniel johnson johnson
launches one high and deep to right
forget it way on out of here
home run daniel johnson and the indians
take the lead two nothing
oh my
425 feet the distance
as johnson hits his third home run on
the season
to give the indians the lead
well i'll tell you what he was quick to
the baseball on that swing on a fastball
middle in watch how quick the hands are
getting through the hitting area in the
intent the corners nobody out two
nothing tribe in the sixth now the 1-0
swung on hit a ton to deep center field
back goes ref snyder on the track at the
wall jumps he made the catch
tagging and scoring rosario throw to
first slide out at first ramirez has
doubled up
a sensational grab in center field by
ref schneider
tagging and scoring was rosario ramirez
had already gone around second he had to
retrace his steps
hit second go back to first before he
could get there ref schneider threw him
out the twins haven't done
much of anything against morgan they got
a lead off single from donaldson might
have cracked his bat in the process a
couple of walks followed a 2-2
swing and a miss
struck him out on another great
change-up
eli morgan gets rooker for the third
time
via the strikeout that's eight in the
game and eli morgan has now set down
eight in a row here it comes
swing and a weak fly ball to right
carries a little bit but near the wall
to pull it down is zimmer
everything's carrying tonight but you
knew as soon as it left the bat
that
donaldson didn't get close to getting
all of it but it's still carried and
jorge polanco the right guy batting in
this spot twins are down three nothing
bases loaded and nobody out and the
first pitch is swinging a ground ball
right side likely to clement has it
second for one the return will be late
they only get one
as gordon scores kepler to third looked
to be taylor made but polanco beat the
return throw from jimenez here's josh
donaldson boy was that a big out now the
2-2 delivery
swing and a mess he got him with a
hanging curve ball
i think that hanger surprised donaldson
sometimes you can make a mistake pitch
and the hitter is so stunned
that he doesn't crush the hanging
curveball
so now runners have second and third
with two down three to one the indians
leading it here's luisa rise
swung on a tamper to short rosario has
it throws him out how about that
arise looked like he swung at ball four
but nonetheless the indians got him out
the ground ball out to short emmanuel
clause will try to nail it down three to
one indians bottom of the ninth
swung on fly ball right field not deep
zimmer's there ball game so the indians
have even the
series had to win a piece
with the rubber mats coming up tomorrow
afternoon at 110 cleveland time
[Music]